foreign
[Music]
ER Jen Wilson and welcome to this film
independent presents q a for the Sony
Pictures classic documentary turn every
page The Adventures of Robert Caro and
Robert Gottlieb by Lizzie Gottlieb
special thanks to our lead sponsor the
hifa and our virtual screenings partner
Vision media and now please welcome our
guest director Lizzy Gottlieb thank you
so much for joining us Lizzy thank you
I'm so happy to be here
um so we have a lot of film independent
members that are aspiring filmmakers and
because of that I usually ask a question
at the top of our guest how did you
become a filmmaker oh gosh well I was a
theater director for a very long time
um I started and ran an Off-Broadway
Theater Company in New York
and I had a kind of lightning bolt
moment of a documentary I wanted to make
about my younger brother who's autistic
and I suddenly thought I'd been thinking
I should make a fiction film about him I
thought oh my God it should be a
documentary literally sat up in bed one
morning with this thought and
I was working with a guy who was a
Broadway producer and we were out one
night and he said I want to change my
life and produce documentaries and I
said oh I have a great idea for one he
said great I'll produce it how long will
it take you and I said it'll take me six
months and it took me six years
because I think I had this slightly
arrogant feeling that like oh I
understand storytelling so it's not that
different from theater but of course
it's very very different and I I think
making it fun but your family is also so
complicated so it took me a really long
time to figure out how to do it and I
kind of learned as I as I went along on
that one what is that film called that
film is called today's man it was on PBS
okay
great I'll have to check that out
um so this this film is about uh author
Robert Carro and his working
relationship with his longtime editor
Robert Gottlieb
um they wrote the Pulitzer Prize winner
um the power broker together
Robert Carroll wrote it Robert Carroll
wrote it was edited by Robert Gatlin
um
I have to say that I'd never heard of
this book or either one of these guys is
it
is it a very Niche kind of book that
only a certain group of people have read
because now I'm fascinated and really
want to read it but um you know Carol
was written to he's written the power
broker and then he has been writing this
series of books about Lyndon Johnson for
50 years right and Caro I'm going to get
to your question I'm just giving some
background you know Caro
writes as he says not just the stories
of of important men but he writes about
how power Works in our country and how
power
affects the powerless
and so I think those books have meant an
enormous amount to a lot of different
people in a lot of different areas you
know people in government people in
urban planning people who are interested
in history people who are interested in
power of all kinds so are they Niche
books I think it's a quite large Niche
but I
and I think people who've read them feel
that they're in on some secret kind of
society of people who understand how
things have actually happened in our
country
um but I really wanted this film to work
for people who have read the books and
loved them and are on the edge of their
seats about when the next one will come
out and also for people who've never
heard of them do you know I think
um
to me the film is about
a collaboration about you know creative
collaboration about joy and work
um so many things also about what does
it take to kind of get to the truth of
what has happened what is happening you
know all of these things dedication to
craft so so I hope that the film
is
meaningful to people who love the books
and also meaningful to people who
haven't read them and maybe never will
read them
um yeah I found this completely
fascinating and of course their
relationship which we'll talk about in a
second also completely fascinating
um so a spoiler alert Robert gottlieb's
actually your dad
true and uh when uh when about when did
you first start to think that you should
make a talk about about
um Bob does he go by Bob Carroll yeah
Bob Caro and your dad Robert Gottlieb
was a little bit of a white whale for me
this film you know I am
I
had this very strong feeling
that this film would work and that it
would matter
um and I don't really know why because
um a story about two very old guys whose
activity is sitting in chairs and
putting words on paper does not really
seem like a cinematic Bonanza
um but I just felt so strongly
I'm going to back up a little bit
I grew up in this house where my dad's
writers were always part of our family
you know close close friends and I had
never met Robert Carroll
so there was something different about
this relationship and at a certain point
some years ago about seven years ago I
heard Bob Carroll give a speech about
his working relationship with my father
and how contentious it is and how they
disagree over semicolons
and it just started I I just started to
think there's something there because
I wasn't really interested in telling a
story like I'm a great writer or a great
editor but the thought of this dynamic
between them this relationship that's so
thorny and complicated and productive
and in fact ultimately I think quite
loving
I just thought what a window into
the world of book publishing you know
which I think people read books but
nobody really knows how they come to be
and I thought what an incredible
opportunity that was to look at that and
to look at this history
of 50 years of this relationship
developing and these books coming to me
to be
and also it's an ongoing relationship
there the Robert Carroll was trying to
finish his last volume of his last book
he's 87 years old my father is 91 and
they're in this Race Against Time to try
to finish their life's work so there's
so much at stake for them
and for us you know the readers who want
to have the story revealed
and so much at stake for me personally
as my father is 91 and I'm sort of
trying to hold on to every moment I can
with him so it felt important and maybe
even urgent to tell the story right now
so in the scene where
your dad is going through the bookstore
um and talking about the books that he's
edited and holding up things like catch
22.
talking about how he suggested the title
is that is that his grandson with him in
the scene that's my son okay yeah yeah
um you know editors I feel like editors
really get short shrift unless you're in
the publishing and world of literature
and writing
I you know I feel like writers would
definitely know who your father is but
it feels like you know it's like films
like the director gets the credit for
films and the author of the book gets
the credit
but when for writing the book but
um
your dad is really a an extremely
prolific editor and I don't know
very much about the editing world but he
says he might have he might have edited
700 or 800 books is that a lot for an
editor today
accomplish in their lifetime I think
it's quite a lot
um it's true you know the job of an
editor is to disappear right my father
says in the film it's a service job
you're in service of the book
I think it's you know well we can talk
about the difference between that and a
film editor which I think is a different
job but but in both cases your job is
right to disappear to make the work
better
um so if an editor is if is famous or
getting a lot of attention maybe they're
not doing it right in some way right
um but I
so it makes sense that my father is
known within the literary world but not
so much outside of a literary world I
think he has added a lot a lot of books
I mean he started as an editor in 1955
and he is still going so that's a lot of
years yeah
um and he's very very fast and very very
focused and industrious
uh so there's a lot of yeah he's done so
much in all that time
well as they say in the movie that he
can read a book overnight which I don't
know if he still does but he not
he not only reads that book he gives
that the attention and editor's
attention and gives notes
that's insane
I wouldn't even hope to be able to read
most books in in one night
uh had he always had this skill of being
able to read that quickly
he says that he had to learn to slow
himself down when he became an editor
because he's a very fast reader so I
think what he does is he reads
everything he gets overnight
um
as a first read for first impression so
that he can call the writer the next day
you know he's always said that's the
greatest thing you can do as an editor
is have a swift response
um because the authors are out there
waiting waiting to hear what you think
they're hard on their sleeve
so I think he reads them overnight and
calls the next day with his response and
then he goes in again and works on them
and edits them and goes back and forth
with the writers and he still does that
I also oh sorry go ahead it's a lot to
live up to
I actually I actually totally related to
that because he says at one point like
yes I do do that but also you know
please note that I don't like regard it
as a task I want to read it
I can't wait to read it so when uh when
I say like how many hundreds of movies
I've seen in a year people are like why
would you ever do that and it's like oh
I don't have to I want to like I do this
for my job but I also want to you know
it's like kind of an obsessive feeling
um because you just want to see all the
movies that there are
um I think that's one of the things I
wanted to capture is this incredible joy
in work and both of these men you feel
are unbelievably galvanized and joyful
might be too uh I don't know what that
word is but they're they take incredible
joy and pleasure in their work and I
find that so inspiring
your dad so your dad says something you
say
to your dad you know Bob Caro has has
agreed to do this but he won't be in the
same room with you and
and your dad says well do you blame him
um those are one of my favorite scenes
in the movie and your your dad has such
a tremendously dry but hilarious uh
sense of humor
um and Robert
Caro is like a little more
straightforward which makes them kind of
a comedy duo in a way
but I think that you're right in that
their relationship is so
it's strange but it's also really taught
their commitment to this work is really
touching and that you know when you end
with that scene of them sitting like
shoulder to shoulder with their pencils
and the manuscripts
doing it like I never imagined that
that's how books get edited I thought
someone just sent it as a PDF or as a
you know dot docx
to an editor's computer and then the
other just edits by itself themselves
and send it back I didn't realize it was
such a personal communication
I'm not sure it always is but in their
case it definitely is and you know
somebody who saw the film at a festival
a couple weeks ago said to me this film
is a love story and they don't get
together till the last scene
I loved that I loved that comment and I
think she's right it does I I do think
that is something we were crafting you
know we were given this kind of
when Bob Carroll said he would do the
movie but he didn't want to be seen in
the same room as my father that struck
me as so
um hilarious and a little bit enraging
and quite touching and also sort of
irresistible you know okay we're gonna
creep after these guys
who are creeping after these historical
figures and we're going to try to
capture something
um but I think you know neither guy
wanted to make this movie I asked my
father first and he said absolutely not
he's quite Fierce about it and I kept
asking and he finally said well you can
ask Bob Carroll but he's going to say no
and
I called Bob Carroll because he doesn't
email of course so I had to pick up the
phone and call him and asked him and he
said
no I don't speak publicly about my work
or my process and he said but I saw a
film you made that I quite admired so
why don't you come and talk to me
so I did and he gradually over that
conversation said all right I I've never
actually seen a film about a writer and
an editor and I think it might be
important to show this to people
and I think he thought it would take me
a couple months to make this movie I
don't think he thought it would take
seven years
um but as it started to take more time I
think maybe he felt yeah recognized
something in me and he was like oh
that's my kind of girl she takes a long
time to make a movie but I felt that his
softening towards the filmmaking and
towards me over the course of that
period
I thought was a kind of important
element in the film that they both kind
of open up more and more towards us and
and and towards each other you can
really see that in the film Because by
the time you get to Texas
with uh Bob and Aina
you can tell that he likes to his liking
setting and and talking to you he like
he's very he's thought out way more than
at the beginning of the film where he's
just giving you like little breadcrumbs
about what's going on
um and then you know the ultimate is
when he shows you where he puts his
uh
um copies up above the refrigerator in
his house it's like oh you hit the
jackpot
um I was so like my jaw was on the floor
when he shut up the refrigerator I
really couldn't believe it I felt so
lucky to be there to be seeing it
these I mean there's something about the
both of them that's incredibly quirky
like when they first meet
and then so they're making their plan as
to when they're first going to get
together and and Bob suggests lunch and
your dad's like oh no I don't go out for
lunch
so they get a sandwich and they say it's
like who doesn't go out for lunch okay
he was he was just when he was running
knot for not having lunches he's like
it's a waste of time I need to work I
need to work he said he once went out
for a two Martini lunch and then he
would he spent three days recovering and
he said never again just gonna stay home
stay in the office get the work done
it's very it's like I have a friend that
will only come over to my house if it's
at 6 30 and there is a parking space
right in front of my house for her
since that quirkiness
but I love it
I love that I love that about people
they're very specific you know
things that they have adjusted their
life to
um you know I have to say
if someone had given me Robert Cara's
book The Power broker
and said and and said to read it and I
sort of looked him up and look at like
what he writes I probably would have
been like
this is a dude that that writes about
powerful white guys like that sounds so
grody
um but watching this movie and hearing
him talk about why he you know wrote
about Robert Moses and about LBJ volumes
and volumes about LBJ
uh it's it's
it really won me over
um because the why of it is fascinating
and you said it perfectly in the
beginning you said writing about people
who have power for people who don't have
any is that how you said it
well Lisa Lucas says in the movie she
says
um he's well he he's writing about the
effect of power on the powerless and she
does if we understand power and what it
does to people who don't have it then
maybe we can imagine a better future
yeah and I do think that Bob Carroll
has an unbelievable ability to go after
you know there's this scene where he
writes about Lyndon Johnson's cook
who the Lady Bird and Lyndon Johnson
traveled from DC back to Texas every
summer
and they made their cook travel Drive
herself across the country with all
their fancy dishes their China and their
dog
but she as a black woman
in America at that time with a dog was
not allowed to stop anywhere to stay or
to use a bathroom
and that Cairo has tracked her down and
is writing about her experience in
service of Lyndon Johnson to me is such
a strong example of what he's doing he's
talking about you know that's tiny but
it's also governmentally he's talking
about how Robert Moses's plans destroyed
neighborhoods he's talking about the
racism that was built into the actual
structure of New York City that we're
still living with today
so his kind of
Relentless search for what these
powerful men did to the people who
didn't have power is
unbelievably
awe-inspiring yeah you know as Majora
Carter says in the film she says it's
not just that he had empathy he says use
this information she says it weaponized
the work that she is doing today and I I
think that's right and I think that's
why
so many people care so deeply about
these books
do you think that um
that your dad in his career has
specifically chosen works like this that
have like a powerful message for people
you know I'm not sure there's a theme to
The what the books are about and for
idea like I have a lot of them right
here behind me
um I think that he has looked for always
books that are
deeply effective that that that
are that work that are great great
stories and sort of the writers who are
at the top of their
abilities in the top of their craft so I
think that's what he cares about the
most and then his job is to try to make
them better if he can
I love the part at the end where you
where you ask Bob Carroll if his
research into politics and power gives
him
hope for our political future or despair
can you talk about what his answer was
and what you think it means yeah
I was nervous to ask him that because I
feel that he's a little bit of an oracle
right you know he if he doesn't know
then nobody knows he's found out
everything there is to find out
um
and I asked him once if what he thought
about what was going on now in our
country and he was like I can't I have
to keep my head in the 60s I can't talk
about what's going on now so it's like
he couldn't talk about it directly but I
finally said you know
does researching power as you do make
you more or less hopeful for our country
and he gives this really profound answer
that I'm always every time I watch it
I'm still sort of on the edge of my seat
like what is there hope for us I feel
that we're saying and his answer is that
there's unbelievable hope for
the potential of what government can do
he talks about Medicare and Medicaid and
how that changed people's lives and I
think he talks about what Lyndon Johnson
did for civil rights and how that
changed so many people's lives and then
he talks about the devastation of
government
in the Vietnam War
and then he ultimately says it's not
hope or fear it's all that he's in awe
of what government can do
so
I don't know what we take from that but
there's a lot to take from that I was
really glad that's what the answer was
I was like yes okay it's good and I felt
like you too I was like if anybody knows
this guy does in
I was very relieved that that's what the
answer was but he is also you know what
he says his books are hoping to he says
if we understand power then maybe we can
vote better and maybe we can have a
stronger democracy
so in his search for the truth his sort
of unrelenting search for the truth of
what has happened and what can happen
therefore
I think he's telling us we have to it's
a call to action yeah
I have to tell you you know when you
when you visit uh
that cabin
um in in Texas I don't know if that was
the Johnson fan family's cabin or one
like
what he lived in but it looks almost
just like
um this cabin that's by where I grew up
I grew up uh in Illinois
near the Lincoln Log Cabin which was
Lincoln's parents cabin that they lived
in while he was president
and
you know it's a it's a dirt floor
two-room cabin
and
um
like one probably link it that Lincoln
grew up like as a child and it's just so
striking I didn't realize that LBJ had
grown up that way it makes you wonder
how much their upbringing
contributed to their determination
you know because it was so so meager and
so basic how much that contributed to
their drive to make it
to the top
um so on a last note
um
it's so touching the the sticky note
that Robert puts on his they put it on
his lamp on his writing desk the only
thing that matters is on this page
did you ask him why that's the phrase
that he puts on his sticky note I didn't
ask him but I I will say that we
definitely kept that in the Forefront of
our mind you know
Karis is the only thing that matters is
what is on this page and as
as somebody making a film about him I
think I kept thinking the only thing
that matters is this film that we are
making we have to make this the best
possible film we can do you know so to
have we had that on the one hand of my
father's motto which is not in the film
is he says there are three things get it
done do it now check check and check
again so we had these two sort of
Commandments from these two guys that
really kept moving us forward
and
I think are very inspiring you know do
the work get it done but also that
make the best possible thing you can
possibly make it's what I took from Bob
Carroll's index card
I think he feels the same way about
research and writing that I do which is
like research yeah it's so fun
writing uh
God the worst the worst it's so
interesting when you hear great writers
still say that their writing is hard and
has never gotten any easier isn't it
um but also it's it's pretty inspiring
because you know it it sort of makes you
feel like oh I'm not the only one that
has a hard time with this and just
because I have a hard time doesn't mean
that I should stop doing it you know
well thank you so much for talking with
us about this movie it's so special and
I love it and thank you for making it
and please tell your dad Thanks for
making it I know he didn't want to
um when does the movie come out it comes
out in theaters on December 30th okay
well congratulations I feel like people
are gonna love it and
um congrats to you and good luck to you
thank you so much
[Music]